manchmal meine damen und herren ist es
ganz schön kompliziert
wir verstehen unser gegenüber beim
besten willen nicht oder fühlen uns
selber total missverstanden
ein erster schritt sich besser zu
verstehen ist sich in den anderen
einzufühlen und in seine haut zu
schlüpfen
das sagt mein heutiger gasthaus forster
er selber treibt dieses bestreben auf
die spitze um das gegenseitige verstehen
zu schulen schlüpfte er ins leben aus
dax otto fuchs mauersegler und rothirsch
und sagt er habe dadurch auch vieles
über den menschen gelernt
herzlich willkommen ja fast dass sie
sind eigentlich ursprünglich anwalt
heute vor allem medizinethiker an der
universität oxford vor kurzem sind sie
aber auf allen vieren durch den wald
gekrochen haben sich würmer genehmigt
sie haben als rothirsch gelebt und sich
vom blutenden jagen lassen
hier sehen sie hier in ihrer rolle als
rot hier schließlich gerade ein
nickerchen machen
vermissen sie ihr leben ist ihr manchmal
wir alle leben ein leben heißt ihr auch
wir sind tiere ob wir wollen oder nicht
wir sind zwar mehr als tiere
aber wir bleiben tiere ich habe versucht
mit einigen unserer engsten
evolutionären cousins in kontakt zu
treten
wir müssen nur ein paar seiten in
unserem familienalbum zurückblättern
bevor wir zu den schuppigen und pelzigen
gesichtern kommen
wir verstehen besser was uns als
menschen ausmacht wenn er verstehen
woher wir kommen
ein möglicher weg das zu tun ist in ihre
lebensform einzutreten mitleid und
empathie zu entwickeln ist anstrengend
aber es wird einfacher wenn man lange
genug daran arbeiten eine ausgeklügelte
zoologische schauspiel methode wie ich
sie angewandt habe könnte helfen die
muskeln der empathie zu stellen
die sachen werden wir auf jeden fall
noch sprechen aber wenn sie zurückdenken
an diese zeit jetzt sind es ja wieder in
ihrem büro an der universität gibt es
dinge die sie vermissen was sie denken
ich wäre gerne wieder malen docs oder
ein otter ich vermisse die intensiv
der beziehung zur natur aus der spezies
hervorgegangen sind
wir wissen dass wir mit der natur tief
verbunden sind dass es uns schlecht geht
wenn wir nicht ins grüne schauen können
dass patienten in krankenhäusern viel
schneller gesund werden wenn sie die
aussicht auf einen baum genießen können
wir wissen dass es autistischen kindern
in jeder beziehung besser geht wenn sie
draußen sein können
wir wissen dass ein zynischer ceo der
die produktivität seiner angestellten
maximieren will sicherstellt dass sie
vom arbeitsplatz aus einem baum sehen
kann was ich sagen will wir sind teil
der natürlichen welt und funktionieren
viel besser wenn wir diese beziehung
anerkennen
ob ich es also vermisse im wald herum zu
kriechen ja die meiste zeit verbringen
wir in einer sehr natürlichen umgebung
was nicht zu unserem wohlergehen
beiträgt
es ging mehr im wald den gerade gesehen
haben weit besser als wir nicht durch
ein riesiges einkaufszentrum gehen und
dann kam ihnen die idee wirklich so ein
experiment zu starten das ja dann auch
beschrieben haben in diesem buch der
geschmack von laub und erde die ich
versuchte auf tier zu leben also wann
haben sie sozusagen entschieden wirklich
diese tiere sich auszuwählen und ganz in
diese lebenswelt zu schlüpfen
nun alle kinder machen die ganze zeit
genau das was ich in meinem
exzentrischen experiment getan habe
jedes kind krabbelt auf allen vieren
unterhält sich mit seinem haustier nimmt
seinen teddybär ins bett das ist ganz
normales menschliches verhalten gesunde
kinder haben eine sehr enge beziehung
zur natürlichen umgebung so wie ich sie
als kind auch hatte ich hatte ein
besonderes erlebnis ich bin in
nordengland aufgewachsenen kinder im
garten hinter unserem haus in sheffield
gab es eine amsel ich meinte unseren
garten hinter dem haus gut zu kennen
aber diese amazon schien etwas über den
garten zu wissen was ich nicht wusste
wir schauten uns in die augen und ich
wollte in erfahrung bringen was der
vogel wusste was ich nicht wusste
seither lässt mich diese frage nicht
mehr los sie ist so grundlage viele
meiner persönlichen interessen und
inzwischen auch akademischen
untersuchungen geworden was können wir
wissen eine der erkenntnistheoretischen
fragen welche die philosophen seit
jahrtausenden beschäftigt sie ist für
mich von höchster bedeutung
ich weiß nicht was sie von mir sehen
wenn sie mich über diesen tischen weg an
schauen dass wir gar nicht wissen wie
sehr wir uns eigentlich einfühlen können
lassen sie uns diese philosophische
frage noch kurz auf später verschieben
interessant ist ja wenn wir mal noch
beim experiment bleiben dass sie
eigentlich schon sehr viel erfahrung
haben sie haben jetzt auf ihre kindheit
verwiesen dass alle kinder eigentlich
eine sehr enge bindung haben zu tieren
aber sie haben ja auch eine weile lang
sehr viel zeit investiert im sie jagen
von tieren und sie sagen auch in diesem
buch das kam in ein stück weit so gut
sie waren schon geübt darin auf dem
bauch zu liegen im wald und ganz lange
zuwarten hirsche zu beobachten wild zu
beobachten genau zu gucken wie bewegen
sich die tiere wie verhalten sich diese
tiere aber was sie heute nicht mehr
machen ist sie schießen eben nicht mehr
auf die tiere ich glaube sie haben alle
gewehre verschenkt das wollen sie also
nicht mehr tun jahren ist nicht mehr
hobby ich habe diese phase meines lebens
bereut ich habe dadurch viele praktische
fertigkeiten erworben wie sie soeben
gesagt haben beim jagen entsteht ein
inniges verhältnis zwischen dem jäger
und seiner beute
dieses entsteht zum beispiel nicht
zwischen einem vogel und dem beobachter
der den vogel durchs fernglas betrachtet
wieso das so ist es ist ein mysterium
worüber ich in diesem seltsamen buch
spekuliert habe ich habe die jagd
aufgegeben weil ich meine lektion
gelernt habe durch die intensive
verbindung zu den tieren im experiment
für mich ist der tod von
nicht-menschlichen tieren moralisch
gesehen eine ernsthafte angelegenheit
darüber sollten wir gut nachdenken bevor
wir einen burger beißen denn es grenzt
an einen kannibalischen akt ich bin kein
vegetarier aber ich agiere nahe an der
grenze zum kannibalismus
das bringt mich in einen anstrengenden
moralischen rechtfertigungsdruck
man muss schon ein sehr großes vergnügen
die bayern finden um das töten unseres
evolutionären cousins zu rechtfertigen
macht es denn sehr spaß in einen big mac
zu beißen
ich werde deswegen ja wohl nicht
verklagt für mich ist es kein großes
vergnügen einen big mac zu beißen aber
durchaus eines in einige der muskeln
meiner andere cousins zu beißen
schauen wir uns mal 'nen teile ihres
experimentes genauer an nämlich ihr
leben als dogs das war eines der tiere
die sie sich ausgesucht haben
der dax ist jan tier das gräbt sich eine
höhle mit den eigenen trotzen wir sehen
hier bin davon wachsen die bauen sich
ganze gänge unterirdisch und leben dann
da gemeinsam in diesen höhlensystemen
die dachse sind relativ gemütliche tiere
die sonnen sich auch mal gerne wieder
machen auch eine pause machen auch gerne
nickerchen und wenn sie kinder haben
dann sind sie sehr familienfreundlich
und kümmern sich um ihren nachwuchs
schön ja das sind wunderschöne tiere
dass ich auch ehrlich gesagt ich habe
noch nie einen dax gesehen so im regen
land ist er sehr bekannt
die meisten leute kennen den dax leider
nur von verkehrsunfällen als
zerquetschten haufen am straßenrand auch
der fall ist ehrlich gesagt dass er wie
gesagt ich habe noch nie ein solches
tier gesehen ich weiß natürlich wie sie
aussehen aber eigentlich nur von bildern
sie haben ja mit ihrem sohn zusammen
einen solchen box bau sich selber
irgendwie hergestellt gebaut sie haben
darin geschlafen in diesem bau kann man
da schlafen wenn da sorgen tiere über
einen kabeln würmer aus den wänden
gucken kann man wirklich schlafen
derzeit bringt man braucht eine weile
wir menschen sind formbare geschöpfe und
gewöhnen uns mit der zeit an die meisten
umstände
es dauert gar nicht so lange bis man
sich daran gewöhnt in einem erdhügel zu
leben natürlich ist er seltsam die wände
des erdlochs um einen herum sind wie ein
großer uterus es ist wie in einer
gebärmutter zu leben geboren zu werden
und heraus zu kriechen an die
spezialisten
es war interessant ich habe das gemacht
was ein laienschauspieler macht es war
lustig in eine andere rolle zu schlüpfen
man lernt mehr über sich selber wenn man
in die schule oder die pfoten eines
anderen wesen schläft was machen sie
wenn sie hunger hatten wir aßen was es
da eben gar ja wir haben regenwürmer
gekostet das ist eine sehr anmaßen der
passage in einem ich habe versucht zu
beschreiben wie ein wurm schmeckt in der
sprache des wein kritikers spreche vom
terror harten boden den mann aus dem
körper des wurms heraus schmeckt ich
bereue sehr dass geschrieben zu haben es
ist anmaßend und dumm und sagt überhaupt
nichts über das leben der dax aus es
sagt nur aus welchen wortschatz ich
haben habe um zu beschreiben wie würmer
den menschen schmecken
es ist für das thema unwichtig schlecht
geschrieben tatsächlich in allen
interviews die sie geben kommt diese
wurm stelle sozusagen zur diskussion
weil sie einfach so unglaublich lustig
geschrieben ist weil sie so ganz genau
beschreiben was der wohl in ihrem mund
macht wie der beginnt sich darwin zu
wehren und dann irgendwann aufgibt da
versucht zuerst durch die zahnlücken zu
kriechen und dann klingelt er sich
irgendwo in einer ecke des landes
zusammen und schläft ein und sie sagen
das ist eigentlich war es gar nicht in
ordnung ich hab aber ich muss sie auch
noch fragen was genau ist das motiv
warum denken sie im nachhinein dass ich
nicht wirklich in ordnung haben dieses
gefühl sie werden dem tier nicht gerecht
oder sie machen sich fast lustig über
diesen wurde über den dax oder warum
bereuen sie diese stelle weil es ist
nicht bar 13 gesetzt waren sie nicht gut
beschränken
sie sind sehr nett bezüglich meiner
schreibversuche danke aber es ist
zügelloser anthropozän tourismus und
beschreibt los eine menschliche reaktion
auf etwas worauf ein dachs
sich anders reagiert hätte das war mir
eine lehre ich habe wenn sie so wollen
die frage des prüfungs experten nicht
beantwortet
jetzt nennen sie den eindruck prozent
riss muss also diese vorstellung dass
wir sozusagen immer nur aus menschen
sicht auf die tiere gucken und sehr
menschlich eigentlich argumentieren
können wir den diesen anthropozän
tourismus überhaupt ablegen wir bleiben
ja menschen die sich können wir nicht
vollständig ablegen
ich konnte mich in all den jahren in
denen ich für dieses buch geforscht habe
nur für sekundenbruchteile dem andere
prozent riss muss entziehen
aber der anthropomorphe muss eignet sich
gut als erster schritt wenn man
herausfinden will was ein nicht
menschliches tier aus der welt macht
denn wir haben sehr viele
gemeinsamkeiten bezüglich der
evolutionären geschichte und der
physiologie wir sind neurobiologisch
gesehen zu weiten teilen gleich
gestrickt
wenn sie also erfahren wollen wie es für
einen dachs ist aus dem gehölz zu
schauen dann tun sie gut daran wenn sie
von dem ausgehen wie es für charles
forster ist wenn er aus dem geld schaut
es braucht natürlich noch viele
korrektive ich denke man kann etwas
lernen von der welt der tiere
auch wenn man sie mit menschlichen augen
betrachtet besonders dann wenn wir
unsere menschlichen sinne so gebrauchten
wie sie ursprünglich gedacht waren was
heute kaum mehr der fall ist
beispiel gibt für so einen moment habe
gesagt es gab millisekunden indem sie
das gefühl hatten sie verschmelzen mit
dieser tierwelt gibt es eine bestimmte
erinnerungen die sie da denken
dachse sind tiere mit einem ausgeprägten
geruchssinn ihre landschaften sind die
gerüche die landschaften für uns
menschen sind vorwiegend visuell denn
vision und kognition sehen und erkennen
sind
aneinander gekoppelt wenn ich zum
beispiel einen baum betrachte dann wird
dieser baum unmittelbar zum gedanken den
ich charles forste von einem baum habe
ich lebe fast nur in meinem eigenen kopf
der baum wird zu meinen erinnerungen von
bäumen in poetischen gedanken über bäume
das hat kaum etwas mit dem baum selbst
zu tun das verursacht allerhand
schwierigkeiten auf welche dir
vielleicht noch zu sprechen kommen
ein dachs erschnüffelt den baum er macht
keine kognitive augen schnüffelei stelle
ich mir so vor der baum ist für den dax
nichts anderes als sinnes daten seines
schnupfens ich konnte den baum nur für
sekundenbruchteile erschnüffeln ohne
gleich das riechen in meine visuelle
darstellung und meine vorstellung die
ich vom baum habe zu übersetzen
ich bin überzeugt dass jemand der
feinfühliger ist als ich vielleicht
weiblich vielleicht legasthenie mit
einem offeneren blick auf die welt mehr
zum verstehen des dachses beitragen kann
vielleicht weil ich absolut
das klischee ist richtig frauen sind
natürlicher weise sehr viel mehr
beziehung zu lesen als männer
vielleicht erreichen wir männer das auch
wenn wir daran arbeiten wir starten aber
mit einem beträchtlichen nachteil meiner
erfahrung nach auch tierarzt das ist ein
stück weit auch mediziner gibt es da
wirklich irgendwelche studien die das
belegen
ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt wenn das
vom hören sagen aber ich bin kein
experte auf diesem gebiet wäre ein
weiteres experiment vielleicht können ja
mal als frau leben dann wäre das ist
dann das nächste buch darüber werden wir
auch sprechen sprechen wir noch einmal
über den docks es gab viele momente
überhaupt in ihrem tierexperimenten da
mussten sie auch den äther überwinden
also sie haben würmer gegessen sie haben
versucht das ganze tehran zu markieren
mit eigenen code mit urin und es gab
natürlich auch situationen als rothirsch
da mussten sie lernen wieder zu können
also gras zu fressen ist zu erbrechen
und waren irgendwie wieder zu essen gab
es im moment wo sie gedacht haben jetzt
bin ich
vollkommen verrückt warum tue ich mir
das an oh ja es gibt viele solche
momente aber ich denke das trifft auf
die meisten momente in meinem
alltäglichen leben zu das ist keine
besonderheit dieses experiments die
meisten teile der meisten menschen leben
sind außergewöhnlich und eigenartig wenn
man genau hinschaut
ich denke nicht dass es etwas
außergewöhnliches ist sich wie ein
rothirsch oder ein dachs zu verhalten
was ich da getan habe gehörte früher für
fast alle menschen zum bewährten
alltagsgeschäft nur moderne
gesellschaften betrachten dies als etwas
seltsames ich werde ihn also eine
klassische verrückte antwort geben auf
den vorwurf ich sah ein irrer sie lautet
ich bin ganz normal gute antwort wie war
es denn mit ihrer frauen ihren kindern
sie haben sechs kinder ein kind tom der
war acht jahre ja damals dass mit ihnen
mitgekommen der mochte dass das leben
auch sagen sie war der bessere dax auf
sie selbst aber wie hat ihre familie
reagiert von dir ev das siegen ja auch
prima was sie da machen
meine frau ist eine geduldige und
verständnisvolle frau sie hätte mich
nicht geheiratet wenn sie mit meiner
eigentümlichkeit nicht umgehen kann
außerdem sieht sie dass es für die
gesundheit unserer kinder förderlich ist
mit der natürlichen welt verbunden zu
sein
die kinder ist das überhaupt nichts
ungewöhnliches
sie machen was sie machen würden sie
krabbeln herum bauen höhlen halten sich
im wald auf kinder spielen auf
baumhäusern oder in erdlöchern das tun
kinder in jeder normalen kultur ich habe
meine kinder auf einige dieser abenteuer
mitgenommen aus verschiedenen gründen
zum einen liebe ich meine kinder
wir haben spaß zusammen aber auch weil
kinder viel weniger vergessen haben
von der natürlichen welt als wir ich
denke platon hatte recht der prozess
etwas zu erkennen ist der prozess der
anamnese
das nicht vergessen kinder haben viel
weniger von der welt vergessen als wir
das auch ein plädoyer für eine andere
form von erziehung oder schule
es ist ein plädoyer gegen die
überheblichkeit der erwachsenen
sie wüssten alle antworten und das
kinder getrennt werden müssen sich auf
eine bestimmte art zur welt zu verhalten
vieles entspricht nicht der natürlichen
beziehung zur welt
das macht uns als erwachsene unglücklich
und funktionsunfähig und das macht die
welt auch zu diesem verheerenden ort der
sie ist wir verwüsten unsere welt kinder
machen das nicht um auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen
meine kinder waren meine großartigen
lehrer in diesem projekt es wäre
lächerlich gewesen ihre hilfe als
lehrmeister und ratgeber über bord zu
werfen
und wenn schon gehen wir zurück zu ihnen
als kind sie haben am anfang schon
erwähnt wie sehr sie die an sie gemacht
haben und das eigentlich ihre geschichte
mit den tieren mit der amsel begonnen
hat in ihrem garten
sie beschreiben in diesem buch auch
wunderbar wie sie in die amsel nester
gekrochen sind sie haben ja schon
gesammelt sie haben getrocknete
ansetzungen gesammelt ihr vater brachte
ihnen auch regelmäßig mal ein
überfahrenes tier nach hause dass sie
dann zitieren konnten sie hatten ganz
frisch und diesen drang ins tier
einzudringen und an einer stelle sagen
sie und sie haben es auch schon erwähnt
dass sie den eindruck hatten diese amsel
habt ein geheimnis haben sie den
eindruck sie sind dem geheimnis der
amsel irgendwann auf die spur gekommen
nein ich bin kein geheimnis nicht einmal
meinem eigenen auf die spur gekommen
ich habe keine ahnung was in den köpfen
meiner frau meiner kinder und meiner
besten freunde vor sich geht erst recht
nicht was in ihnen visa wie von mir
abläuft was in anderen köpfen steckt
bleibt ein ewiges geheimnis und das
lässt uns mit einem unbehaglichen gefühl
zurück ich denke es lohnt sich deshalb
umso mehr herauszufinden was im kopf
einer amsel vor sich geht was für eine
welt sie bewohnt das hilft uns bessere
freunde bessere liebhaber bessere väter
zu werden
ich denke ich habe einen winzig kleinen
fortschritt gemacht
und der weiß wert interessant ist ja
dass sie jetzt gesagt habe wir wissen
nicht was im kopf vorgeht und
tatsächlich haben sie auch ein hirn
einer amsel in formalin eingelegt bei
sich aufbewahrt ich habe sie gefragt ob
sie es nicht mitbringen könnten sie
haben gesagt das ist bei ihren eltern zu
hause aber das scheint noch zu
existieren dieses einzel hier aber warum
denken wir eigentlich dass sich niemand
nein zu fühlen primär bedeutet ins hirn
reinzukriegen also haben sie selber
seine auffassung auch aus bioethiker das
dass ich der amsel oder ihr ich nur im
kopf ist oder haben sie auch die
vorstellung dass ich das irgendwo im
körper noch bestehende das ja sehr alte
philosophische frage ich habe mir diese
frage mit sieben jahren natürlich nicht
in diesen begriffen gestellt aber ich
habe realisiert dass das gehirn etwas
sehr bedeutsames leistet das zu tun hat
mit der vermittlung zwischen uns und der
welt so habe ich gemacht was jeder
schamane in jeder kultur auf dieser welt
getan hätte den tier nahe zu kommen in
dem ich einzelne seiner körperteile
nutzte das ist ein eher seltsamer zugang
ich tat es und irgendwie hat es
funktioniert es war eine intuitive sache
die ich offenbar machen musste diese
sehnsucht und gleichzeitig das scheitern
daran ist ja auch so eine philosophische
frage und sie haben jetzt immer schon
wieder gesagt es ist eine menschliche
erfahrung dass wir noch so viel wissen
sammeln können über ein anderes wesen
trotzdem werden wie nie wirklich wissen
wie es sich anfühlt dieses wesen zu sein
und das ist eigentlich die position von
thomas niggl der 1974 diesen berühmten
aufsatz geschrieben hat die ist es eine
fledermaus zu sein und beschreibt darin
einen forscher von fledermäusen der weiß
alles über fledermäuse als er weiß alle
empirischen daten er beobachtet
fledermäuse er kann genau beschreiben
die fledermäuse funktionieren und
trotzdem
ja nie wie es sich anfühlt kopfüber von
einem baum zu hängen als fledermaus das
ist ja eigentlich glaube ich die
grundidee ihres buches dass sie
versuchen herauszufinden kann man doch
irgendeinen fortschritt machen und wenn
ich sie richtig verstanden habe sagen
sie man kann fortschritte machen aber
wir werden nie an den punkt kommen indem
wir wissen so fühlt es sich an eine box
zu sein
richtig ich denke thomas nagel wird oft
missverstanden wenn er die frage
gestellt wie ist es eine fledermaus zu
sein
dann fragt er eigentlich ob es etwas
ähnliches wie das bewusstsein gibt oder
ob das bewusstsein mit nichts anderem in
der welt zu vergleichen ist
es ist aufgrund der gemeinsamen
evolutionären geschichte und der
ähnlichen physiologie durchaus ein
sinnvolles unterfangen zu versuchen
nicht menschlichen wesen nahe zu kommen
und somit auch den menschen das wahre
hindernis ist sprachlicher natur
wir haben bereits darüber gesprochen wie
beschreibe ich einen baum
indem ich aussagen mache diese aussagen
sind aber meine ganz persönlichen sie
sagen kaum etwas über das wunder aus
dass in einem baum steckt ist es möglich
sich dem sprachlichen zugang zur welt zu
entziehen
ich denke schon wir machen das ständig
in vielen anderen lebensbereichen
stinker steven pinker verzweifelt am
unterfangen das leben anders als so
sprache vermittelt zu verstehen
ich denke das ist zu pessimistisch wenn
wir ein musikstück hören
dann werden auf eine andere nicht
sprachlicher art gefühle evoziert wenn
ich musik höre dann übersetzt sich die
empfindungen die sie auslöst nicht in
sprachfetzen die ich danach
interpretiere ich spüre diese gefühle
auf einer tieferen ganze
die höheren ebene was wenn ich sie
beschreiben würde ich schätze das was
ein komponist durch sein musikstück
ausdrücken will mehr als dass ein
schriftsteller durch seine prosa
ausdrücken will
wenn ich sein text lese viele unserer
anderen bedeutungsvollen arten sich der
welt zu nähern wie etwa berührung geruch
manchmal werden nicht zwingend
sprachlich übertragen
damit sage ich dass es grund zum
optimismus gibt
wir sind nicht auf ewig daran gebunden
die welt nur sprachlich wahrzunehmen was
die meisten informationen über die welt
ausschließt wird exklusiv story
information damit machen sie eigentlich
zwei dinge ist das eine das jetzt
ansprechend ist eigentlich so die these
für des späten wittgenstein dir gesagt
hat die grenzen meiner sprache sind die
grenzen meiner welt und sie zitieren
eine andere stelle im buch sie sagen
nämlich wenn ein löwe sprechen könnte
dann würden wir nicht verstehen und das
ist auch wittgenstein und die idee ist
wir verstehen eigentlich sprachspiele
immer nur vor dem hintergrund von
lebensweisen und ansonsten können wir
nicht verstehen wenn wir an das leben
haben die auch eine andere sprache und
werden uns nicht verstehen
sie sagen aber wittgenstein irrt also
das heißt wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
auch wenn wir nicht die gleiche sprache
sprechen gibt es andere vermittelte
welten in denen wir uns treffen können
zum beispiel musik und dann verstehen
wir uns ist dass die idee ich denke es
ist unsinn zu sagen dass wir keine der
anderen sprache sprechen können die
wichtig sind für nichtmenschliche und
auch für menschliche tiere
es gibt ebenen wo wir uns begegnen und
austauschen können
mir kommt das sehen was ich sehr
interessant finde uns die sind ja auch
bioethiker eine frage die sich viele
menschen stellen ist wie kann ich zum
beispiel mit einer person kommunizieren
mit der ich immer gute gespräche hatte
die plötzlich dement wird und die meine
sprache nicht mehr spricht und die auch
ein stück weit in einer neuen lebenswelt
zu leben scheint und da haben wir ja
dieses gefühl dieses total fremden
so fasst dass wir die uns ein tier
gegenüber sitzen wir haben zwar noch die
gemeinsame erinnerung aber wir haben
keine gemeinsame sprache mehr werden sie
sagen auch da ist es möglich sich
einzufühlen und so eine neue form von
begegnung zu schaffen
absolut denn für die echte tiefgründige
art miteinander zu kommunizieren braucht
es die sprache überhaupt nicht sie
können zum beispiel das gesicht von
jemandem berühren das erlebt man nicht
wenn man sagt er hat die hand
ausgestreckt und mein gesicht floriert
sprachlich gesehen ist das nichts
großartiges die gäste hingegen schon sie
ist von großer bedeutung
auch die musik die wir gesprochen haben
spricht vielmehr ebenen an tiefere
uralte ebene
ich vermute dass wir in unserer
evolutionsgeschichte musikalische tiere
waren bevor wir zu sprachlichen tieren
geworden sind dass wir diesen
musikalischen sinn auch mit vielen
nichtmenschlichen tieren teilen und
trotzdem frage ich mich ist das nicht
unendlich viel schwieriger mit den
tieren also dass man einen menschen
berühren kann und davon ausgehen kann
dass man die reaktion des gegenübers
irgendwie korrekt deutet ich glaube
damit sind wir vertraut bei den tieren
ist es doch so endlich viel schwieriger
und da interessiert mich schon wie sie
das geschafft haben nur ein beispiel ich
hatte als kind meerschweinchen und ich
habe die sehr oft gestreichelt und dann
haben die geschnurrt würde ich ihm sagen
so wie ihre kleine katze und ich dachte
immer dass meerschweinchen freut sich
bisher eine tierärztin more gesagt hat
das ist eigentlich ein zeichen von angst
dass wahrscheinlich ein markt das
überhaupt nicht und die war tief
schockiert sagt ich habe das
meerschweinchen nicht verstanden also
wie können sie natürlich tierarzt sie
wissen sehr viel mehr
aber wie können sie erkennen ob ein tier
zum beispiel das streicheln mag es gibt
physiologischen stress oder auch
emotionen der freude die wir im labor
messen können
das ist eine tatsache dass suggeriere
nicht dass wir wie doktor dolittle zu
tieren sprechen können dass sie uns ohne
vermittlung verstehen würden
social media sind ich lege nur eine
langweilige aber bewährte beobachtung
nahe
wir menschen haben viele physiologische
mechanismen mit den tieren gemeinsam und
wir teilen dieselbe welt wir können mit
diesen geschöpfen durch denselben
waldstreifen wir können aus unseren
physiologie lehrbüchern lernen was
angenehm ist und was stress erzeugt wird
ein wenig vorstellungsvermögen kommen
wir einen kleinen schritt weiter im
verstehen der welt der tiere
ich hätte bevor ich meerschweinchen
angeschafft habe mich genauer
informieren sollen was meerschweinchen
mögen und ob dieses streicheln
eigentlich überhaupt artgerecht ist gut
dass heute geholfen
ich war noch ein kind sich zu einer
entschuldigung sagen wenn ihr noch
einmal thomas nagel bleiben und bei
dieser ich nenne sie mal eine gewisse
verzweiflung diese verzeichnung dass wir
das so genannte fremd psychische nie
wirklich erkennen können ich kam nie
wirklich wissen was sie wirklich fühlen
bis hin zu ich weiß eigentlich nicht
einmal ob sie ein bewusstsein haben oder
ob sie vielleicht ein zombie sind der
nur so tauß wäre ein mensch das macht
man ja manchmal auch sehr unglücklich
also dieses gefühl von tiefen
missverständnis man sieht mit einer
person am tisch und denke einfach was
bist du denn für einer
du verstehst mich überhaupt nicht ich
bin so einsam haben sie den eindruck
etwas von dieser einsamkeit überwunden
zu haben indem sie besser gelernt haben
sich einzufühlen also kann man von
tieren etwas lernen fürs verstehen
zwischen menschen und tablet wird ich
bin fürchterlich besorgt dass die ganze
welt die es gibt nur das ist was in
charles forsters kopf stattfindet alles
was es gibt ist das was ich ins leben
rufe in dem ich die sinnes daten
manipulieren
die in meiner rezeptoren eindringen ich
bin besorgt darüber dass auf der ganzen
welt alles nur auf sich selbst bezogen
ist ich will aber überzeugt werden dass
es da draußen eine objektive realität
gibt
aber sie halten es für eine möglichkeit
in so einer matrix zu leben wo es keine
wirkliche realität ringsum gibt sondern
die ganze herrlichkeit ich das glaube
ich grundsätzlich nicht aber manchmal
ist es schwer mich selbst zu überzeugen
dass das nicht der fall ist wenn ich
mich davon überzeugen will das ist nicht
der fall ist betreibe ich aber keine
wissenschaft und mache auch nicht so
verrückt es wie durchs gehölz krabbeln
und würmer essen dann trinke ich ihr ein
glas wein mit meinen freunden oder gehen
dem park mit meinen kindern die sorge
dass alles nur eine virtuelle realität
ist die ich charles forster geschaffen
habe verpufft und für einen moment aber
die philosophische sorge die bleibt ich
denke das ist teilweise die folge
unserer sinnlichen armseligkeit damit
meine ich wir haben mindestens fünf
sinne thomas von aquin sagt wir hätten
neun und er hat wohl recht wir haben
mindestens 55 hat er noch bei gefühlten
sich auf engel zu beziehen und
derartiges hat sicher recht aber auf
alle fälle können wir uns einigen auf
mindestens fünf sinne
doch wir nutzen normalerweise nur einen
davon als folge unserer
evolutionsgeschichte
und das ist das sehen nehmen wir an dass
visuelle sinnes daten ganz unverfälscht
durch unser gehirn fließen was in
wirklichkeit nicht der fall ist
denn sie werden unmittelbar durch unsere
wahrnehmung verfälscht aber nehmen wir
jetzt an und stünden alle unsere
visuellen sinnes daten zur verfügung
entscheidungen darüber wie die welt ist
fällen wir dennoch in dem wir uns nur
auf 20 prozent aller unserer sinnes
daten stützen
wenn wir aber entscheidungen über
beziehungen fällen oder über berufliche
dinge oder über irgendetwas anderes und
uns nur auf 20 prozent der vorhandenen
informationen stützen liegen wir aber
falsch und wir verstehen auch die welt
nicht recht haben wir vernachlässigen 80
prozent der informationen die uns
eigentlich zur verfügung stünden
aber ich denke es gibt da etwas in uns
dass uns intuitiv erkennen lässt dass
wir nicht das vollständige bild hat die
unstimmigkeit zwischen dieser intuition
und unserem gehirn das darauf beharrt
die 20 prozent seien bereits das ganze
bild schafft so etwas wie ein und
logisches unbehagen das unserer modernen
mannes zu grunde liegt
ich erinnere mich gerade daran dass vor
kurzer zeit hier thomas moser gesessen
habt ein blinder mann mein kollege poß
hat hat ihn interviewt und er hat für
mich sehr eindrücklich davon erzählt wie
es ist nicht zu sehen und wie dann eben
andere sind plötzlich sehr viel
wichtiger werden dass man die ganze zeit
denkt es wäre eigentlich ganz gut nur
mal für eine woche nicht zu sehen um
lernen zu können die man hören kann wie
viel man riechen kann wie viel man
tasten kann also das ist sozusagen der
punkt dass wir unsere sinne wieder
schulen müssten vielleicht ein bisschen
wie ein tier das eben andere sinne zur
verfügung hat richtig eine großartige
übung
ich habe letzthin über jemand gelesen
der von geburt an blind ist und sich
selbst das navigieren durch echoortung
beigebracht hat und zwar so weit dass er
mit dem fahrrad durch den rollenden
verkehr fahren kann
außergewöhnlich ein weg den geruchssinn
der normalerweise vernachlässigen mehr
aufmerksamkeit zu schenken ist und die
augen zu verbinden so wie ich es in ein
paar verrückten experimente gemacht habe
welche im buch beschrieben sind
wenn sie sagen in dem dass wir unser an
vielen schulen in andere menschen
vielleicht eben auch zum beispiel in
blinde menschen oder in demente menschen
aber eben auch in tiere dann kann die
unglaublich viel lernen und wir werden
vielleicht auch verständnisvoller im
umgang mit anderen menschen
dann könnte man ja sagen naja ist eine
gute idee zu versuchen sich auch in
andere lebenswelten zu begeben und eine
extreme idee hatte eine hotelkette das
hotel im jahr in bloemfontain in
südafrika bietet ferien an ins lamm
[Musik]
ja in diesem slum hotel konnte man
ferien machen das ist mittlerweile
geschlossen worden lägen sehr viel
kritik man konnte in diesem slum
häuschen beifall empfangen man hat die
zentralheizung grundsätzlich wäre das
eine gute idee und die leute zu
sensibilisieren für den lebensraum von
anderen menschen nun diese spezielle
umsetzung finde ich etwas bevormundend
doch die zugrunde liegende idee ist gut
aber ich denke es muss nicht so
aufwendig sein
wir brauchen nur von unserer gewohnten
sichthöhe rund 180 cm runterzukommen und
damit ein paar millionen jahre
zurückzugehen auf das niveau des bodens
dort leben die meisten unserer
evolutionären verwandten
das ist viel billiger als ein flug nach
südafrika ich glaube worauf ich hinaus
wollte ist diese frage auch wie lernen
wir uns eigentlich überhaupt einzuführen
da gehe ja auch sagen mitleid zu
empfinden mit anderen menschen hat ganz
stark damit zu tun überhaupt zu
verstehen wie es sich anfühlt in einer
bestimmten art und weise zu sein
ich mache mich zum beispiel gut erinnern
dass ich meinen kindern einen an einem
parcours teilgenommen hatte da konnte
man im rollstuhl einen parcours abfahren
und die idee war natürlich genau den
kindern verständlich zu machen
wie ist es unterwegs zu sein wenn man
nicht gehen kann und die randsteine
diese hoch sind nicht überfahren kann
und das hat glaube ich dieses hotel
versucht es gibt ein anderes beispiel
die ngo habitat die sich bemüht häuser
behausungen für menschen in armut
herzustellen
die hat einen erlebnispark auch eröffnet
wo man in verschiedenen solchen islam
siedlungen vorbeischauen kann sich damit
erlassen kann
um eben die sensibilität von menschen
für die lebenswelt von weniger
privilegierten menschen zu schulen
großartig problem wahrscheinlich ein
weit schnellerer weg auf dem man lernen
kann wie man sich als mensch entwickelt
schneller als mit meiner methode
nun gibt es ja auch grenzen des
verstehens und dieses einführen und sie
sagen in diesem buch auch es ist ihnen
nicht immer gelungen in diese tiere
hineinzukriechen sozusagen
es gibt momente in denen man einfach
merkt man versagt
olli ist es mir gelungen lassen sie mich
klarstellen
das buch ist ein volltreffer was das
scheitern anbelangt es enthält
gelegentliche bruchstücke von
brauchbaren material
es lohnt sich aber das zu tun jemand
anders eine feinfühlige hre personen die
besser schreiben kann als ich hätte mit
denselben methoden wohl mehr daraus
gemacht als ich das aber es gibt ein
bestimmtes tier bekommen die sie an ihre
grenzen nämlich der otter sie haben
irgendwann gesagt es gab zeiten als
opfer da wurden sie depressiv weil sie
gemerkt haben ich will kein opfer sein
irgendwie war es schwierig da zu sein
warum nun es war nicht so schwierig
sondern schlichtweg unmöglich
irgendeines dieser tiere zu sein
genauso wie es unmöglich ist sie oder
ein anderer mensch zu sein
ich fand die annäherung an die otter
weit schwieriger als diejenige an andere
tiere
das hat mich wirklich schockiert weil
ich als kind die mutter liebte wie die
meisten kinder
doch deren leben ist so rastlos sie sind
sechs stunden am tag wach sie haben
einen massiven stoffwechsel bedarf wenn
sie ruhen ist ihr stoffwechsel grund
umsatz um 40 prozent höher als jene
eines hundes und wenn sie im kalten
wasser sind sogar viereinhalb mal mehr
als bei einem hund um am leben zu
bleiben müssen sie unmengen fressen für
mich würde das bedeuten einen bigmac
alle vier minuten
das so und wer alle vier minuten einen
bigmac verschlingt ist wohl nicht das
geistreiche gegenüber mit dem man sich
gerne bei einem
und essen unterhalten würde ich fand es
nicht besonders angenehm in ihrer
gesellschaft zu bleiben ob die
ingenieure keyword company schauen wir
uns diesen ort hat doch einmal an diese
theorie gibt es ja in der schweiz auch
es sind tiere die im wasser schwimmen
und sie haben es schon erwähnt die
brauchen unglaublich viel energie haben
einen ganz hohen metabolismus er ein
schwimmender potter und die jagen fische
die sie dann ganz verspeisen
haben sie eigentlich je einen fisch
gefangen und so gegessen und schreibt
nun ich habe es versucht
es ist mir nur einmal als kleines kind
gelungen aber es war ein fehler der mich
mit abscheu erfüllte warum werfen fehler
nun ein anderer junge mit dem ich
spielte hatte eines tages gesagt ich
solle einen fisch in den mund stecken
ich tat dies mit einem kleinen fisch den
wir gefangen hatten und bis
versehentlich hinein keine schöne sache
ich habe aber versucht fischer mit
meinen zähnen zu fangen es klappte nicht
wir sind einfach zu langsam sie haben
vorhin gesagt es war eigentlich ihnen
nie möglich sich in ein tier einzufühlen
aber bei motto gab es ja wirklich diesen
moment zu schreiben sich zumindest im
buch wo sie den eindruck hatten sie denn
depressiv weil sie so sehr scheitern im
sich einfühlen und das haben sie auch
dass sie da etwas gelernt haben über
sich selber nämlich die tatsache dass
wir schlechte freunde sind wenn wir
nicht glücklich sind oder dass wir
schlechte freunde sind und uns nicht
einfühlen können wenigstens selber
schlecht geht wie genau meinen sie das
ist dann sozusagen unser
einfühlungsvermögen wie betrübt
also mit kontext robert das war in
zusammenhang mit meiner kleineren
depression die ich hatte mir scheint
eines der dinge welche eine depression
anrichten kann ist dass das
selbstwertgefühl schrumpft und als das
geschah wurde ich eine noch
unangenehmere person für meine freunde
und familie als ich es ohnehin schon bin
je mehr mein selbstwertgefühl schrumpfte
um so selbstsüchtiger wurde ich
ironischerweise und kommen aber auch
davon lernen dass man eigentlich selbst
liebe praktizieren muss um andere
menschen liegen zu können
sonst lassen und ja das ist wesentlich
leute die sich selbst hassen passen auch
andere leute ja und trotzdem denkt man
ja auch immer es gibt ja auch ein
egoismus der trend aus es scheint um ein
ausmass zu gehen man muss irgendwie mit
sich selber im reinen sein um auf andere
menschen zugehen zu können
aber wenn man sich zu sehr liebt und zu
sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt ist
dann entsteht ja auch eine barriere
also es geht mir darum das richtige maß
zu finden so gewiss schon das
aristotelische gleichgewicht was meinen
sie damit dass du der beste ort liegt
zwischen den beiden schädlichen extremo
jack streams wie sieht es mit t
sozusagen das in der tugend lehre die
idee wir sollten nicht zu sehr ins eine
oder ins andere extrem sondern den
goldenen mittelweg verfolgen ist das
auch etwas was sie denken durch haben
sie hier gelernt in diesem ganzen
experiment wie wichtig es ist selber
irgendwie bei sich zu bleiben und
trotzdem offen fürs gegenüber zu sein
aber das hat sich nicht erst durch
dieses seltsame experiment ergeben
ich denke das kommt von meinem
kostspieligen herumstreifen in der welt
etwas was mich auch sehr interessiert
hat in diesem buch ist unserer umgang
eigentlich mit der wild haltung dem
tierischen in uns selber sie sagen ein
stück weiter alle haben etwas wildes in
uns aber wir sind uns nicht mehr gewohnt
damit umzugehen
wie genau meinen sie das oder was ist
das problem sofern es unsere
revolutionäre entwicklung betrifft sind
wir seit viel längerer zeit menschen als
erst seit dem pleistozän
nun sind wir in der post neolithischen
phase
wir sind jetzt körperlich und politisch
bauern jungsteinzeitliche all unsere
prägenden erfahrungen stammen aus einer
völlig anderen welt in welcher wir viel
enger in ein ökosystem eingebettet waren
als heute
bis zur landwirtschaftlichen revolution
wir sehen uns jedoch so wie uns die
genesis im kapitel einzieht als krone
der schöpfung all unsere reflektionen
und gedanken über uns selbst sind im
unterbewusstsein zweifellos
konditioniert durch diese frühen jahre
warum mag ich es denn an weihnachten an
einem gemütlichen feier zu setzen
nicht weil ich ein sentimentales bild
habe bis charles dickens beschreibt wie
weihnachten mit der familie sein soll
sondern weil ich wenn ich in die tiefe
des unterbewusstseins blicke fürchtet
dass ein wolf kommt ich fühle mich
sicher weil ich ein holzstück aus dem
feuer nehmen kann um dem wolf das
gesicht zu zerschmettern
deshalb bin ich das was ich bin und wir
täten besser daran diese prägenden
erfahrungen ausdrücklich anzuerkennen
es ist ebenso war dass wir auf einer
bestimmten ebene immer noch teil der
wilden natur sind wie bereits gesagt es
geht uns auch besser wenn wir bäume
anschauen kann sogar der gott von
monsanto der ceo dieses chemiekonzerns
ist voller wilder unkontrollierbarer
bakterien auf welche er aber angewiesen
ist um zu überleben
wie teuer unsere anzüge auch immer sein
mögen
darunter sind wir immer noch sehr
spezielle wilde kreaturen ich sage ich
dass menschen nicht etwas ihr
bemerkenswertes und ungewöhnliches sind
wir sind und bleiben immer tiere
vielleicht sind wir noch einige dinge
mehr aber wir bleiben hier
sie leben ja wirklich in diesen beiden
welten also sie lieben die natur sehr
und leben aber gleichzeitig an einer
sehr sehr guten universität in oxford wo
er berühmte leute ausgebildet werden
akademischen klima und das interessiert
mich wie ihre meinung dazu ist mir fällt
auf dass zum beispiel sehr viele leute
wieder dieses buch lesen von henry david
thoreau wollen das hat immer wieder
jetzt neu ausschlagen gegeben feiert
auch ein jubiläum dieses jahr dieses
buch das stand ja von 1854 er zog dieser
frau aus wollte der industrialisierung
eigentlich entfliehen im jungen amerika
hat sich niedergelassen an einem kleinen
teich und wollte in der stille zu sich
finden und interessanterweise gibt es
seit kurzem auch ein magazin das war
dann heißt das ich an die an die
städtische bevölkerung fast schon
beendet indem man eben wieder lernen
kann wo man eigentlich in der natur sich
wie zurechtfindet wie man fische die man
holz hat wie man feuer macht und so
weiter mein eindruck ist den bau
interessiert mich ihre meinung dass das
enorm zugenommen hat dass diese
sehnsucht nach der natur etwas ist was
in den letzten jahren sehr viel
verstärkt da wieder aufbricht
teilen sie diese einschätzung komplett
ich stimme völlig zu es gibt einen
spürbaren hunger nach authentizität und
nach anerkennung jenes teils von uns den
wir auch sind wir müssen anerkennen was
wir wirklich sind
wir müssen uns gewahr werden dass unser
authentisches ich seinen platz in der
wilderen welt hat ebenso müssen wir uns
unsere schuld bewusst werden was wir der
welt antun von der wir doch eigentlich
ein teil sind wir verwüsten unser
eigenes zuhause
das macht mich jetzt fast schon wie soll
ich sagen optimistisch wenn ich das
sagen denn alle diese sehnsucht hätten
zum beispiel was sie mit der natur
machen dann müsste man nur sagen
in den usa beispielsweise müssten die
klimaziele beispielsweise doch etwas
sein was politisch verfolgt werden
müsste aber man erlebt doch eigentlich
jetzt zum beispiel auf der politischen
ebene eher das gegenteil dass man
plötzlich wieder der eindruck habt
klimawandel kleiner ziel ist auch nicht
so wichtig ja wir verhalten uns
politisch und in vieler hinsicht auch
persönlich in einer weise gegenüber der
natur die offen gesagt psychopathisch
ist es gibt eine spannung in uns selbst
und dadurch auch in der gesellschaft
zwischen kolonialer ausbeutung und der
anerkennung einer verwandtschaft mit der
natur
diese spannung gibt uns ein schlechtes
gewissen wie es auch sein sollte und
macht uns persönlich unglücklich viele
unserer neurosen lassen sich wohl auf
diese spannung zurückführen
sie sagen auch dass diese sehnsucht nach
der natur nachdem begegnung mit dem
wilden in uns drin dass wir eben
aufgrund der evolution immer noch in uns
tragen
doch manchmal auch eine interessante
schlaufe sozusagen macht sie sagen
nämlich manchmal ist uns das bild der
natur lieber aus die wirkliche natur um
die haben eigentlich eine
kolonialistische vorstellung von der
natur können sie uns doch mal ein
beispiel geben was sie da genau meinen
dass die gesamte das beste beispiel bin
ich wenn ich in den wald gehen dann
zurückkomme und nicht ans pult setzte um
über die natur zu schreiben was ich dann
normalerweise an meinem laptop tour
ich beschreibe die vorwegnahmen die ich
bereits in den wald mitgenommen habe ein
im grunde kolonialistische unterfangen
ich beschreibe eigentlich was in meinem
kopf steckt einmal mehr eine
selbstbezogenen übung
ich bin kaum so demütig dass ich
versuche wahrzunehmen was dieser wald
für sich selbst ist wie er sich den
geschöpfen zeigt die den wald viel
besser kennen als ich eben wie er
wirklich ist diese große
erkenntnistheoretische frage
normalerweise interessiere ich mich
meist nur für charles forster in
charleston
die meisten modernen schriften über die
natur
meine eingeschlossen ist eine art
literarische masturbation ein stück weit
kann man nichts dafür wir menschen sind
und leben anthropozän trish bleiben aber
sie appellieren daran diese grenze zu
überschreiten
wenn sie vom demut sprechen ist das für
sie auch eine moralische haltung also
finden sie auch wir sollten demütiger
der natur begegnen
ja ich anerkenne dass die natur uns
hervorgebracht hat ich anerkenne dass
unsere physische und psychische
gesundheit entscheidend von der natur
erreicht
ich anerkenne dass wir mit der
neurologischen hardware und software die
wir bekommen haben viel mehr schätzen
könnten in welcher außergewöhnlichen
welt wir leben
diese welt ist viel bunter
charismatischer und wundersamer als wir
zu gestehen
sie können so wunderbar von der natur
erzählen dazwischen habe ich mich auch
gefragt hat für sie die natur auch so
etwas wie ein ist das für sie auch eine
religiöse erfahrung natur zu erleben
viele menschen sagen dass sie ein
sonnenaufgang beispielsweise die taub
allen auf dem graf das hat auch eine
religiöse qualität ist es für sie auch
so ich kümmere mich in diesem kontext
nicht um religion höchstens um
spiritualität
ich empfinde freude ich spüre ein
transzendente staunen beim betrachten
der welt ich fühle auch dass die welt zu
mir spricht sie gerührt ebenen in mir
die normalerweise nicht angesprochen
werden aber sich für eine unterhaltung
eignen und das ist für mich prägender
als die meisten ebenen denen ich viel
zeit gewidmet habe
leverage spend time talente und wenn wir
das experiment noch weitertreiben
glauben sie eigentlich auch man könnte
sich auch in einen baum ein fühlen was
kümmert das ist zu viel
ich habe vorgeschlagen und ich denke es
ist ein harmloser vorschlag dass ich
mich in einen fuchs einfühlen kann weil
wir viel gemeinsam haben mit dem baum
teile ich nur das schicksal in einer
welt mit voranschreitenden klimawandels
erleben zum schluss vielleicht sie sagen
in diesem buch auch was wir tun können
um unsere eigene wildheit zu pflegen um
unsere eigene wildheit wieder zu
entdecken und mit der natur in kontakt
zu kommen und bringen sie den heiligen
franziskus die sagen nämlich eigentlich
sollten wir wie er den ochsen aus bruder
ansprechen versuchen mit den vögeln zu
sprechen oder zumindest sie als wesen zu
sehen die auch eine sprache haben ist
das für sie auch vielleicht so fasst
eine vorbild figur gewesen
alle kinder machen die ganze zeit solche
dinge kinder scheinen bessere oder
funktionstüchtige menschen zu sein als
ich es bin
es gibt viele einfache dinge die auch
sie tun können sie können ihre dicke
sollten schuhe ausziehen und das gefühl
aufsaugen das durch ihre fußsohlen
hochsteigt
sie könnten sich 180 zentimeter zum
boden herab lassen und beginnen andere
sinnes rezeptoren im kopf als ihre augen
zu nutzen
sie könnten erkennen das ist nur bedingt
zivilisierter orte gibt wie david
abraham der amerikanische philosoph und
naturalist sei wenn sie durch ein
einkaufszentrum in zürich gehen merken
sie dass auch dass ein wilder ort ist
und sie können versuchen diese
überschwängliche welt zu sehen und sich
davon anregen zu lassen
das alles wird helfen ein besserer
ehemann ehefrau freund freundin zu sein
ich werde mich bemühen vielen dank für
dieses gespräch zu verdanken dass sie
hier waren
nächste woche geht hier um etwas was die
einen verteidigen und die anderen führt
nicht existent hatte nämlich unsere
werte
mein kollege in sportart lädt zum
philosophischen streitgespräch über
einen politischen kampfbegriff und jetzt
gleich feiern wir geburtstag vor 50
jahren schufen die beatles ihr album
searching pepper's lonely hearts club
band
die spektakuläre bbc dokumentation zeigt
mit welchen kniffen im studio das album
zum meisterwerk wurde das sollten sie
nicht verpassen
und vielleicht gehen sie danach noch in
den wald und probieren ist zur
abwechslung mal auf allen vieren oder
zumindest barfuß viel vergnügen und bis
bald
[Musik]